starting off this hour is going to be
Jean in Las Vegas hygiene welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi what's up oh no
question I actually just read your Total
Money Makeover book this morning and I
had a question my husband and I and she
just graduated from law school a couple
months ago and so he got a job but I am
was reading to your baby steps and of
course you know step one was the
thousand dollar fast and then step two
is pay off all your debt and I was
thinking about our jet is well it's like
massive so and it's all in school loans
only and it's um about two hundred fifty
thousand dollars plus and so my question
was obviously that's a lot of debt and I
got all excited about no lifting each
one on my debt snowball but it's so much
that I wondered if I should also
continue on to step three and save as
well because I have three little ones
all under the age of three but anyway so
I just want to make you know and he
makes $65,000 a year and I want and of
course we want to be debt-free but we
also you know I want it you know have
money for you know like you know my kids
you know put you know more than a
thousand dollars would be nice and then
ever just you end okay Wow unbelievable
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
I'm so sorry
yes well he does love his job so that's
good and of course go her way of it uh
sixty five thousand bucks a year so he's
a brand new lawyer
they're gonna work him right you're
gonna work him others always wear an 85
Graham yeah and so um what's the
trajectory of his income do you think I
mean what do you see him making in the
coming years so we think that within a
year to he'll be at 80
he just started on salary a couple
months ago and then of course you know
salary is
fabric you know like you said after
taxes Aaron ting but then on top of that
he gets like a percentage you know every
time a case goes through so and then
arrays you know over the next couple
years so we're thinking um probably like
a base pay of a B with maybe some extra
percentage on there from the cases one
okay so we'll go out here's the thing
you guys have a dramatic problem this is
a huge amount of debt I mean I really
want you to leave this call not in
terror but I want you to leave more
concerned than I'm hearing in your voice
I want you guys back because I want your
calling because I want you to focus on
it exclusively if you want to raise the
baby step pulling up a couple thousand
bucks or something that's not the end of
the world that's not obviously you know
from 1,000 to 3,000 or something but
here's the thing you guys have really
the two of you've got to have some
serious talks like you're not going to
see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're work in there you're not going on
you're not going on vacation you're not
buying anything bare necessities for
these kids to eat you to eat and you are
married to a broke lawyer
I mean he's broke this is the the math
of 65,000 versus 250,000 scares the crud
out of me the good news is he can make
more and that's not his projected income
over the long haul and I agree with you
he'll be at six figures income probably
fairly quickly but you guys have got to
keep your lifestyle down to two college
student level lifestyle and so every
time I throw everything at this debt as
fast and as hard as you possibly can I
mean if you if you find $50,000 to throw
at it
that's a five-year plan hopefully you
get to a hundred and fifty thousand and
so then you're throwing a hundred
thousand at it and it turns it into a
three and a half or a four year plan but
yeah I agree with you
I think your your summation is right up
in your case I probably would change my
baby step one a little bit because I'm
afraid you're going to be there a little
while but I'm but you guys can't do
anything don't talk about buying a house
don't talk about buying a car don't talk
about anything I mean get your needle
and thread out and keep the clothing
that you have going I mean it's you guys
have got to roll up your sleeves and
really focus on this because this is a
mess and you're going to wake up 15
years from now and still be looking at
the student loan debt if you don't make
it a huge emotional priority and that's
that's what I prescribed for you and if
I can help you as you're fighting
through this you call me that's what
we're here for I'm going to encourage
you but I want to encourage you to deep
deep sacrifice so that we can move the
needle on this stuff and get it out of
your life and then we can look up in a
few years and you're making 150 or 200
he is and you got no debt at all and
you're used to living below your income
and that's going to put you in a great
position then to win and that's what our
hope for you is long term but that's
four or five years out it's going to be
a little while depending on how quickly
his income comes up and how deeply you
guys sacrifice with your lifestyle but
you don't get to celebrate the fact that
you're married to a lawyer not
financially because you are married to a
broke lawyer Wow hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Music]